في المقابله تهمت الرئاسه الفلسطينيه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه بانها تريد تصعيد
الموقف والجره المنطقه الى الانفجار
والاحتلال ضد الشعب الفلسطيني
وقياداته مرفوضه ومدانه
الخارجيه الفلسطينيه لاجراءات الاسرائيليه
بما في ذلك قرار الصحفي ما تسمى بطاقات في
اي بي الخاصه بكبار الشخصيات في بعض
المسؤولين السياسيين
ينضموا الينا من رام الله الدكتور غسان
الخطيب استاذ العلوم السياسيه بجامعه
بيرزيت دكتور غسان اهلا بك ماذا تحاول
الحكومه الاسرائيليه فعلهم من خلال هذه
العقوبات ضد السلطه الفلسطينيه
بالدرجه الاولى وانما هي عقوبات جماعيه ضد
الشعب الفلسطيني اولا اييي مصادره اجزاء
كبيره من اموال الضريبه الفلسطينيه هذا
سيؤدي الى الحد من قدره الحكومه
الفلسطينيه على الافاعي بالتزاماتها
الخدماتيه في مجالات الصحه والتعليم
وغيرها الخاصه بالشعب الفلسطيني وثانيا
ايضا القرار يشمل تهديدات لمنظمات اهليه
منظمات حقوق انسان
اهليه فلسطينيه غير حكوميه تعمل ايضا في
محاربه الانتهاكات الاسرائيليه لحقوق
الانسان الفلسطيني اذا هي عقوبات جماعيه
وحرب على الشعب الفلسطيني بشكل عام ااه
اذكر بانه العلاقات متدهوره ومتوتره على
همم في الشارع على المستوى الميداني والان
يضاف لها همم منحه جديد في العلاقات بين
المستويات الرسميه الفلسطينيه من ناحيه
واسرائيل لانه من خلال هذه القرارات
اسرائيل تريد ان توجه سلطه رساله للشعب
الفلسطيني بان السلطه يمكنها الاستمرار في
دور الخدمات ولكن ممنوع عليها القيام بدور
سياسي
استفزت اسرائيل بسبب توجه القياده
الفلسطينيه للامم المتحده وتريد ان تقول
ان هذا ممنوع وبالتالي اعتقد ان العلاقه
الفلسطينيه الاسرائيليه على المستوى
الرسمي تمر بمنعطف خطير واساسي وقد يؤدي
الى مزيد من التدهور والتدحرج الى همم
مرحله اللاعوده لان هذه الحكومه الجديده
محكومه باعتبارات ايديولوجيه واعتبارات
شعبويه لن تسمح لها همم
مسايره متطلبات بقاء السلطه الفلسطينيه
وبصراحه قد تكون قد يكون هذا المنعطف
بدايه لتدهور قد يؤدي الى نهايه وجود
السلطه الفلسطينيه كما نعرفها الان هذا
التحدي والاستمرار يعني هذا الامر يطرحه
على السلطه الفلسطينيه حتى يعني تثبت
وجودها كسلطه لها ايضا صلاحيات سياسيه
ووظيفه سياسيه وليس فقط ووظائف كما تريدها
اسرائيل
نعم او وظائف خدماتيكيه بالضبط هذا هو
التحدي بالضبط هذا هو التحدي الاساسي الذي
تواجهه الان السلطه الفلسطينيه وهو تحدي
وجودي لانه اسرائيل وضعت السلطه
الفلسطينيه امام نفترقهم اما ان يقتصر
وجودها ودورها على الخدمات او ان تنتهي
همم او ان تفقد مقومات استمرار وجودها
لانه هذه العقوبات الاقتصاديه في الحقيقه
تاتي خطورتها انها تاتي بعد ان انخفضت
المساعدات الماليه للسلطه الفلسطينيه من
الخارج من المجتمع الدولي ومن البلدان
العربيه
بنسبه الثلاثين خلال الاربع او الخمس
سنوات الماضيه وبالتالي الوضع المالي
للسلطه لا يسمح لها بالاستمرار والبقاء
اذا اقدمت اسرائيل فعلا على تنفيذ هذه
العقوبات الاقتصاديه لذلك نحن على ما
افترق
وامل ان تكون قياده الفلسطينيه على قدر
هذا التحدي واعتقد انه ليس امامها كثير من
الخيارات
المباشره لهذه الاجراءات ستكون على
المواطنه الفلسطيني كيف تتوقع دكتور غسان
ان ان يكون رد الشارع الفلسطيني
بشكل عام يعني كل المؤشرات المختلفه
ودراسات الراي العام وتفاعل الجمهور مع
مظاهر المقاومه ومظاهر الصراع مع اسرائيل
تشير الى ان المجتمع الفلسطيني والجمهور
الفلسطيني لديه استعداد للتحدي ولديه
استعداد للصراع ولديه استعداد ل همم
التضحيه همم وهذا ظاهر من خلال مؤشرات
عديده ولذلك اذا اختارت القياده
الفلسطينيه الاستمرار في المواجهه
السياسيه والدبلوماسيه في الامم المتحده
وغيرها كما جرى
بما سيؤدي له هذا من تفاقم وتدهور في
العلاقه مع اسرائيل فاعتقد ان الجمهور
الفلسطيني سيكون اا يعني عامل ايجابي
وعامل مساعد وعامل متقبل لا بل وداعم لمثل
هذا التوجه الدكتور غسان الخطيب استاذ
العلوم السياسيه في جامعه بيرزيت كنت معنا
من رام الله شكرا جزيلا لك